you ever seen the movie minority report
i know you're not a movie guy i actually
watched it oh yeah you watched minority
report maybe four or five years ago yeah
so in minority report there's do we have
the scene from minority report do we by
any chance of the scene from minority
report
uh uh tyler if you can pull up the scene
from minority report you know which one
i'm talking about just to show there is
a scene in minority report
where they break into this place they
break the window and it's tom cruise
obviously in the movie they break into
this place they break the window
they go in there and then they come in
and they arrest this guy i don't know if
you know the scene and the scene says
we are here to arrest you on a future
crime you're going to commit yeah okay
so i'm getting arrested based on motive
and a future crime right
now
we all know certain things takes steps
to get there right like before you know
a lot of people that are capitalists are
afraid of going to communism before you
get to communism first come socialism
then you go to full control then you
have full control right if you know uh
some people are afraid hey don't touch
my second amendment i want to be able to
have my second amendment first you start
off with
a you know you know let's just say uh ak
for whatever certain weapons you take
then you work your way towards taking a
gun it's like right so people are a
little paranoid saying this is kind of
one which is normal only paranoid
survive
some people are sitting here saying so
you're going to be able to do facial
recognition on me
and let's say you're a nice guy what
makes a thing the next guy that's going
to come or buy you over and he cuts you
two billion dollar check and you take
that check and you say i just built a
company to you know become financially
free my dreams become a reality but the
next guy that buys it says yeah let's
use this
to go find out everything and add
additional
searches on the computer that this
person is doing to see if we can lead to
a potential future crime that's about to
happen then we can use that to arrest
people for crime that they weren't going
to create but we have to trust the
system telling us and i'm asking an
advanced technical question what are
your thoughts about the concern people
have with that i think there's a lot of
concerns and they come from you know a
lot of the media that's happened around
like minority report or other kind of
movies that are you know subconscious
and they you know speak to a lot of
fears that people have uh in reality
what uh where the exact opposite we're
used after the crimes happened so
there's nothing about pre-crimes but you
can advance like you can how do you yeah
how do you know if something's gonna
happen i get that what i'm saying is and
then we have also live in a great legal
system right and i think that's what's
interesting right we have presumption of
innocence you have to prove as an
investigator that uh you know uh and
then you have to prove beyond a
reasonable a lot of people have been in
jail that didn't do anything that's also
true but also in a lot of those cases
come down to things like eyewitness
testimony right so innocence project has
said 70
of people in jail that they get
exonerate that are in there 70 of them
come from eyewitness testimony right if
you had a technology like facial
recognition you can make that a thing of
the past where
instead of eye eyewitness lineup and you
had a photo of the crime scene you can
actually find the real person if it's
accurate or you can exonerate people so
i think uh some of that comes to the
misperception of like how the legal
system works and investigations work and
there's a lot it's been an honor for me
to see how law enforcement actually work
these cases and granted there are some
who are not uh the best but for the most
part most of them that i've met have
been absolutely fantastic and they
take this because it's a division of
responsibilities they you know uh do the
investigations then you have a judicial
system so you have a lot of checks and
balances in our systems unless those go
away then that's the problem whereas if
you see other countries who are more
authoritarian like china and russia they
do apply it in a real-time manner and
that's a world i don't want to live in
uh yeah they
openly showed well i don't know if
you've see i'm sure you've seen it they
show their technology and they say we're
pretty much skynet you know the movie
skynet skynet is uh i haven't seen it
but not not the movies kind of determine
i have some tornado one and two okay
great so this guy is like hey we're here
to protect the world and we're here to
protect people and then the reality of
it is no skynet eventually turns evil so
where china's like no we have skynet but
it's a it's a it's a nice
i saw the i saw the video something got
lost in translation he's like oh yeah
it's nice yeah we're we're a good sky
now we're the ones they have a different
system right like they can detain people
for absolutely no reason in china right
or whatever reason they want to for
indefinite amount of time and that that
real-time monitoring is something i
don't believe in uh that you should do
on maps
you don't believe in and i'll leave yeah
and i do think that
what is interesting is society and
technology co-evolve right so you just
can't take that technology and apply it
the same way here it just wouldn't work
in on many levels and what we did is we
thought about how can we make our system
better right so if there's probable
cause right
if the crime has been committed and all
you have is a photo then they run it
through the system
and then they look at the results and
then they try and make the
identification one great example is
and it's also on our website in our
video is we got a call in 2019 from
homeland security and this is a good
example because it shows how they
actually do investigations and how
powerful it can be and also how it's
done responsibly right
and there was a video of a child abuser
abusing a six-year-old girl and selling
it on the dark web
this is why our customers are very
passionate about keeping the technology
and making sure
it's used properly uh this six-year-old
was being abused and in that video for
just two or three frames it was an adult
face in the background uh kind of blurry
with a beard they put him through the
system at the time
with three billion images there was only
one result he was in the background as
someone else's instagram photo just
working this trade show
um
for supplements so there's no name
attached to him they could click the
link and they had a location in vegas
and so they could find from the photo
that he worked at a certain uh
place
and they could call the employer find
more information from the employer
and then question him and corroborate
the child pornography he was selling and
it's out and
photos on facebook that he had of his
house
in the background and he's been 35 years
in jail so that shows that when a search
result comes up it's just a clue it's
just a lead it's and every photo in the
database is a clue so it's how you use
it and i don't think that uh things like
pre-crime that have suggested in you
know minority report would even be legal
in this kind of system that we have
today you don't think it will be legal
in this country well you'd have to
you know you have to prove that they
violated sometimes i totally get it but
to trust that the government will not
manipulate to get rid of somebody just
the other day the president said
on stage that we have to you know
get rid of this the leader and he's
talking about putin and they came back
and they took it back and now that's not
what i really meant that's not what
really he really meant there's motives
that the government has and they can
figure out a way to take somebody down
if they want to there's many many
different ways
to do that they'll create new laws to go
after a
new person the ricoh change many many
different things have changed
to go after somebody i'm not concerned
about you i'm concerned about who gets a
hold of this technology and takes it to
the next level who would have thought
you know 10 years ago a content creator
is going to be censored who would have
thought 10 years ago a president is
going to be censored but can you imagine
20 years ago saying you know what
clinton is saying is so out of control
we have to silence him can you imagine
40 years ago or 50 years ago silencing
kennedy because what he's saying against
somebody like that's ridiculous but
we're living in that phase so the speed
of advance advancement today
what would be a 10 years
50 years ago is being done in one year
today so people are trying to catch up
so for example the government formats
imperialism
um or monarchy
you have one ruler uh
that does very well louis the whatever
you know and then comes the next one he
doesn't he takes the empire and uses his
power to abuse the people then the next
one comes has to clean up his mess and
the next one comes is the same as the
other guy so whoever's in charge can
typically
turn a good technology into bad
technology that's the concern with a lot
of people so i'm not really worried
about you but it sure looks like we're
headed towards the directional minority
report don't you think
i really don't think so i think this
future is for us to make right and
we're the only company that has this
large database we decided to only serve
law enforcement with it for the reason
is that there's controls on what they do
and what they use it for right uh and
they they're playing a certain role to
investigate crimes and help solve them
and um and then you know we don't think
this database is appropriate for you
know everyone's case watch
let's let's see let's see what's
interesting topic but yeah all i can say
is uh
having seen how they use it and what
they use it for and the success stories
we get every day about saving children
and all this really good stuff it's hard
for me to say that it's a net negative i
think overall it's a net positive and a
lot of the concerns that people have had
uh and that are legitimate still are in
the theoretical stages i i contribute to
multiple uh
charities that go after human
trafficking and i support that but for
us to think that somebody gets a hold of
this to use it in a different way that
the motive is not going to be there i
think it's nice for us to think that
anyway yeah but it's important and we
also vet all our customers we on board
we have the ability to turn off the
customers we vet too much of government
agencies though how do you vet them well
um yeah if we hear that yeah their
accountability is the government they
don't have to tell you nothing they
they're they they we we can go into a
little more but i hear your concerns and
i think i i think that's what's great
about being on your show is to you know
talk about these issues well i respect
the fact that you have the audacity to
sit down and have these conversations
but that that is a
that is a common concern i hear from a
lot of people if you enjoyed this short
clip click over here to watch another
short clip and if you want to watch the
entire episode the entire podcast click
here
[Music]
you